tuez pas comment on pourrait faire moi
je pourrais venir 2 par exemple
oui mais est ce que tu pourrais le faire
une chanson tout tu chantes mairie pleut
déjà donc pas bah c'est sympa merci aux
élèves de la classe de chant du
conservatoire régional de caen répète
dialogues des carmélites de francis
poulenc
la première difficulté c'est d'aborder
la musique de poulenc musique française
qui se basent en premier lieu sur le
texte est donc en fait du texte et la
musique et il a fallu beaucoup
travailler sur l'addiction entre les on
les en faire comprendre ça il faut que
le public comprenne qu'on raconte
d'autant que là il ya des opéras ou on
dit toujours je t'aime plus que ce n'est
pas très intéressant et là chaque mot
est interrogé est ce que tu vas te dire
chaque mot
pourquoi raconter la fin anne ont quand
même très dur
oui oui on disait très éprouvant en
émotions mais quand on a respecté le
final je me souviens on leur répétait
deux trois fois de suite lorsqu'il
fallait congrès que certaines non et je
me souviens c'est toi qui m'as fait la
réflexion
wahou on n'en sort pas des manches à non
dialogue des carmélites et mise en scène
par martin postel professeur de chant
m
son prix surfaits
pour rappel rapidement l'histoire
dialogue lien l'élite donc c'est une
jeune de femme de la noblesse qui veut
rentrer au carmel en pleine révolution
française
voilà
et puis c'est difficile musicalement
aussi c'est quand même ça a été écrit en
57 oui
donc ce n'est pas de la musique
contemporaine au sens hard du défi du
terme mais c'est une amie l'écriture
c'est pas du mozart ce qui a déterminé
mon choix c'est le fait d'avoir un
certain nombre d'élèves pour ses rôles
là car j'ai choisi cette loi je pense
qu'il me permettait de mettre en valeur
les meilleurs élèves de la place
dialogues des carmélites de francis
poulenc
on rappelle les dates c'est samedi 20
heures au conservatoire et dimanche 16h
et c'est gratuit
le grand show des petites choses
les objets détournés par gilbert legrand
mènent leur vie à la médiathèque
d'argentan jusqu'au 14 janvier
et pendant ce temps au musée de
coutances les chant du cygne c'est
l'exposition signée jean la drum
jusqu'au 31 janvier
deux expositions dont on a parlé en 2015
et on a aimé
et puis deux annonces pour finir pour
commémorer les attentats de charlie
hebdo
dimanche à 15 heures place de l'hôtel de
ville à 40 ans des artistes peintres
chanteurs danseurs vous attendent pour
commémorer cet anniversaire
ça s'appelle ami entends-tu demain soir
au cinéma le palace d'equeurdreville il
y aura la projection du film de jérémy
kaplan au rapport justement avec ces
attentats de charlie hebdo
d'abord moi je peux le passage en
adoptant un massacre ils sont venus
massacré toute une équipe le dessinateur
le journaliste ils ont massacré la
liberté la liberté de de parler de ces
fumées
alors je pense que comme tout le monde
j'ai d'abord été horrifiés par ce qui
s'est passé et que
la seconde chose que je me suis dit en
tant que femme musulmane c
et voilà encore sans prendre par la
figure
voilà c'est tout pour ce soir on se
retrouve demain bien sûr